describe el comportamiento de la función
q alrededor de su asiento está vertical
en x igual a menos 3 de aquí nos dan
nuestra función q de x verdad es x
cuadrada más 3 x 2 dividido entre x más
3 muy bien entonces como siempre pues si
ya estás familiarizado con este tema te
invito a que hagas una pausa y trates de
resolver este problema por tu propia
cuenta y si no estás familiarizado de
todos modos vamos a hacerlo juntos muy
bien entonces aquí tenemos nuestra
función q de x verdad esta función es
una función racional es decir es el
cociente de dos polinomios y digamos
cuando estamos trabajando este tipo de
problemas a mí lo que me gusta hacer es
tratar de factorizar todo lo que se
pueda factorizar así que vamos a empezar
con eso vamos a ver si podemos
factorizar este numerador entonces
tenemos que pensar en dos números que
multiplicados nos den 2 pero que sumados
nos den 3 y si lo pensamos detenidamente
pues 2 y 1 funcionan verdad 2 por 1 es
22 más uno es 3 así que esto se
factorizar como x más vamos a poner
primero x más 1 que multiplica a x + 2 y
todo esto va dividido entre x más 3
verdad esta es una forma equivalente de
la expresión anterior y si a lo mejor
está este método que utilizamos aquí te
resulta algo extraño te recomiendo que
veas los vídeos sobre factorización de
funciones cuadráticas aquí en khan
academy muy bien entonces ya con esto
podemos observar algunas cosas por
ejemplo notemos que cuando x vale menos
1 o cuando x vale menos 2 el numerador
se anula pero el denominador no verdad
el denominador sólo se va a anular
cuando x es igual a menos 3 y x igual a
menos 3 es un muy buen indicio de lo que
de dónde vamos a encontrar una cinta
vertical verdad y de hecho recuerden
porque se les llama asiento
verticales se le llama 5ta vertical
porque la función alrededor de ese valor
se ve más o menos así verdad tiene una
cinta vertical o bien puede ser que
crezca por el lado derecho y de crezca
por el lado izquierdo o puede ser que
crezca por ambos lados o de crezca por
digamos por ambos lados también verdad
entonces bueno cualquiera de estas
combinaciones podría ocurrir muy bien
entonces qué es lo que vamos a hacer
ahora digamos que qué tal si ponemos una
recta numérica para ir distinguiendo los
valores que tenemos entonces digamos los
valores importantes que hay que notar
serían menos 3
- 2
-1 verdad estos son digamos como los
tres valores importantes que deberíamos
considerar que de hecho es cuando se
anula el numerador o el denominador
entonces nos preguntan o más bien nos
piden describir el comportamiento de la
función que alrededor de la cinta está
vertical en x igual a menos 3 que de
hecho ya vimos que hay una cinta
vertical verdad entonces la pregunta
ahorita es qué significa esto verdad x
flecha menos 3 menos y en realidad esto
significa que x se aproxima a menos 3
del lado izquierdo es decir con valores
más pequeños que menos 3 verdad son
valores más pequeños que menos 3
entonces en realidad se está refiriendo
lo voy a hacer con un color más más
claro se está refiriendo a todos estos
valores a todos los valores de x que
sean
chicos que -3 verdad vamos a
aproximarnos con estos valores hacia -3
pero del lado izquierdo entonces si
pensamos en que tomamos valores de x más
chicos que menos 3 qué signo tiene este
factor bueno algo más chico que menos 3
le sumamos 1 pues nos queda algo
negativo verdad algo más chico que menos
3 y le sumamos 2 nos queda algo
nuevamente negativo y algo más pequeño
que menos 3 al sumarle 3 todavía nos
queda algo negativo entonces a medida
que nos vamos aproximando a menos 3 del
lado izquierdo obtendremos valores
negativos el detalle es que estos
valores negativos se harán cada vez más
y más y más grandes bueno por supuesto
podríamos pensar lo que serán más
negativos verdad por ejemplo a lo mejor
primero es menos uno menos 10 menos 25
qué sé yo pero el punto es que se van
haciendo más grandes por ejemplo vamos
vamos a intentar con un valor particular
pensemos en q evaluada en menos 3.1
cuánto valdría que evaluado en menos 3.1
por supuesto aquí verdad ese es un
número muy cercano a menos 3 verdad es
muy cercano a menos 3 pero está del lado
izquierdo por digamos que por aquí
estaría el menos 3.1 verdad entonces
menos 3.1 más o no nos da menos 2.1
luego menos 3.12 nos da menos 1.1 y
ahora en el denominador que es lo que
vamos a tener menos 3.13 nos da menos
0.1 entonces aquí es claro que tenemos
un número negativo verdad es menos x
menos entre menos nos da menos verdad
pero estamos dividiendo entre un número
muy muy muy cercano a cero verdad eso
significa que este número en total nos
va a dar muy grande verdad nada más que
va a tener un signo menos verdad e
incluso podríamos por ejemplo nosotros
intentar qué pasaría si ponemos menos
3.01 entonces aquí nos quedaría menos 2
puntos 0 1 aquí sería menos 1.0 1 y aquí
menos 0.01
0.01 y otra vez queda un número negativo
dividido entre un número muy cercano a
cero entonces esto hace que se vaya
haciendo cada vez más y más grande
aunque con signo negativo entonces
podemos decir que a medida que x se
aproxima a menos 3 del lado izquierdo
entonces la función tiende a menos
infinito verdad entonces esta es una
opción o bien podríamos pensar que esta
puede ser otra opción viable verdad el
punto es que cuando nos aproximamos a
menos 3 del lado izquierdo la función se
hace muy grande pero con signo negativo
verdad ahora pensemos que es lo que
ocurre cuando x se aproxima menos 3 pero
ahora es del lado derecho verdad es del
lado derecho eso es lo que significa
digamos esta anotación es decir nos
vamos a aproximar con valores que se
encuentran del lado derecho de menos 3
verdad entonces estos son los valores de
x mayores que menos 3 y llegamos aquí es
menores que
en los dos entonces vamos a dejarle una
bolita abierta verdad ok entonces qué es
lo que ocurre cuando x es más grande que
menos 3 pero más chico que menos 2 bueno
si tenemos un valor más grande que menos
3 x más chico que menos 2
este número de aquí x más 1 sería otra
vez negativo verdad digamos que el
límite sería menos dos más uno que sería
menos uno y es negativo
ahora si x es más chico que menos 2 x +
2 nuevamente será negativo verdad
digamos es un número más negativo que
menos 2 al sumarle 2 sigue siendo
negativo pero ahora x + 3 como sería
bueno si tenemos un número más grande
que menos 3 podríamos decir que es menos
negativo que menos 3 al sumarle 3 pues
ahora nos queda un número positivo
verdad entonces todo esto nos da un
número positivo por ejemplo vamos a
intentarlo con un valor particular q
evaluado en menos 2.99 verdad fue
evaluado en menos 2.99 menos 2.99 está
por arriba de menos 3 y por abajo de
menos 2
y aquí que tendremos menos 2.99 uno será
menos 1.99 esto multiplica a menos dos
puntos 99 2 que es menos 0.99 verdad y
esto irá dividido entre menos 2.99 más 3
que es 0.01 entonces podemos ver que
este número es positivo y estamos
dividiendo entre un número muy cercano a
0 eso quiere decir que todo este número
será muy muy grande lo cual nos ayuda a
ver que a medida que x se aproxima a
menos 3 por el lado derecho
esta función toma valores cada vez más
grandes y positivas es decir a medida
que x se aproxima a menos 3 del lado
derecho q de x tiende a más infinito
entonces digamos la mejor opción que
describe o la opción que describe mejor
a la función verdad alrededor de la 5ta
es esta